[Musique]
pour faire les enfants
j'espère que vous vous êtes bien amusé
aujourd'hui ce que je me lève je vois
pas trop ce que je me suis amusé janssen
est en jeu c'est notre grand ami est
allé au cirque cet après midi et il en
est revenu très content oh oui je te
formidable vous descend vite raconté sa
pa pr baulieu nicolas pour les chaînes
[Musique]
auront au bout
walchi cet après midi les enfants
je suis allé au sur 7 heures fourmies
nord
non je lève mon jeu très bon le site
yahoo
il ya plein de mineurs plaindront
et je me suis assis dans un grand
fauteuil à l'image au nom au bord de la
crise je me suis donc assis j'ai pris
mon sida les hommes cherchent toujours
un cigare aussi c'est pas des vanités
j'ai fait semblant seulement et le
spectacle a commencé la musique
hormis dans
des tambours et puis d'une danseuse très
mignonne sur un fil à la tâche avec eux
depuis sa non elle marche au bout ça
utilise un homme ça y est le danseur
comme ça et se tenait sur un pied en
équilibre sur le style au japon m chami
cana alors comment il s'appelle oh
combien ce que tu es douanes en eau
j'avais des animaux dont jouit des
petits singes est un fait des grimaces
mais je le laissais porter le voile dans
ce rapide n'est pas mais ça of higher
nicolas en faute de von roll
des clowns ya véhicule vous y avait des
couilles je les aime bien les clous ils
me font pleurer un avec un merveilleux
costumes l'inde étoile qui brille et
jouets dollar pointe ce à quoi vous
allez le voir mon chapeau la tullow
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est formidable ce que je suis doué
tout de même
oui patron sa vie
la séance est terminée le cirque ferme
ses portes voilà on aime le cirque du
sénat on ira encore mes enfants en
dormez-vous vite
bonne nuit à damas dans ce stade seuls à
deux pas de là tant bien pas preneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que nounours est doué vous ne
trouvez pas qu'il joue très bien de
l'harmonica aux poteaux
c'est parce que j'ai l'oreille musique
allons aux routes grands musiciens
bonne nuit des enfants endormis vous
bien sagement et faites de beaux rêves
est tout pour l automne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
mon
[Musique]